peut-être une idées de cadeaux de
dernière minute en tout cas une séquence
nostalgie maintenant ce retour en force
du disque vinyle une mode mais aussi un
son différent que les amateurs
apprécient reportage isabelle bechler
dominique bonnet les magasins de disques
d'occasion sont des repères de puriste
de nostalgiques des supports successifs
qui ont accompagné l'évolution de la
musique du xxème siècle à chaque sont
sans support les collectionneurs sont
souvent intransigeant véritable amoureux
des labels anciens de l'esthétique des
pochettes mais surtout du son vinyle
une philosophie c'est vrai qu'on a plus
l'impression d'avoir l'artiste en face
sur certains albums studio on peut avoir
une sensation de live qu'on n'a pas sur
leurs qu'on n'a pas sur le cd que ce
soit sur des originaux par les
rééditions très à la mode aujourd'hui on
a de plus en plus d'occasions de
découvrir l'atmosphère plus sensuelle et
surtout plus massive du son analogique
du rock ou de la variété d'il ya une
quarantaine d'années la reddition aux
vinyles c'est quand même à petit pas
vers l'original
et puis on retrouve ce sont par exemple
le gainsbourg qu'un des listes les plus
célèbres un des plus chers fils hérédité
puisqu'au départ l'original au plusieurs
milliers de francs une nouvelle
réédition mais avec une remasterisation
avec un son qui est peut-être plus
adapté aux chaînes moderne disons la
réédition de vinyles des années 50-60
est une niche pour les grandes maisons
de disques une manière de valoriser un
fonds de catalogue et aussi de conquérir
un jeune public qui a désormais une
platine vinyle grâce au rap est à la
mode dj du vieux pour faire du neuf
créatif pour l'auditeur lucratif pour
l'éditeur et il faut pas se leurrer il
ya beaucoup d'argent en jeu dans les
rééditions des vinyles s'ils le font
c'est parce que c'est commercialement
rentable qui n demande à la fois de la
part des collectionneurs et aussi d'un
jeune public désireux de voir un peu
c'est quoi ce son vinyle qu'on nous
avait toujours caché nous sommes nés
sous l'ère du cellule
à 15 euros le 25 cm vinyle rééditer les
jeunes amateurs de sons peuvent ainsi
découvrir de nouvelles atmosphères se
faire offrir un bel objet au look années
50 et peut-être attrapé le virus de la
collection d'actualité